[Music]
good morning everyone and thank you for
being here for an early morning session
I know it's been a long week for a lot
of you I hope the Google next was fun
and exciting for you for me personally
it was pretty inspiring to see how far
the ecosystem has evolved and all the
opportunities it kind of presents to our
partners to our developers and to our
end-users the topic today we're going to
talk about is Google assistant and how
to build your experiences on Google
assistant I'm terren Jen and I'm a
product manager on Google assistant and
I'm I'm a developer programs engineer on
the Google assistant so let's jump right
in so when we think of Google assistant
there are a few trends that I'm going to
talk about before we set the stage on
how do you build your app for Google
assistant we had an amazing point in
technology where we are really pushing
the envelope on what can technology do
to make things happen for the users to
help them do things in a lot more
seamless and efficient way the first
thing is that interactions are more
natural than ever before so what does
that mean if you think of a simple task
like I'm taking a very very simple
example is do I need to untaken
embroider to work today or I drive up
from the peninsula so doing you carry my
jacket to San Francisco and so on right
what do you what how do you think about
it like you check what the weather is
what time of the day it's probably going
to rain
this probably aligns with the time I
actually take or walk down for my
commute to the train I should carry an
umbrella right now imagine Google
assistant doing that for you which is it
has access to what your calendar is what
your schedule looks like for the day it
knows how often and what times of the
day do you actually take the train it
knows what the weather is for the rest
of the day and can help you and can
recommend you that you need to carry an
umbrella today and then the next thing
is going to be more proactive about it a
very very simple task but we have the
building blocks to do some of these
things now imagine what should I order
for food tonight or what should my
weekend plans should be or which movie I
should be
watching this Friday and so on so the
user expectations around interaction
with Google and on other surfaces that
we have are becoming a lot more natural
the second thing I want to talk about is
the assistant platform the assistant
platforms and are becoming lot more
mainstream so think back a few years ago
if you want to do something you want to
go somewhere you want to buy something
you would go to your mobile phone or to
your desktop or a laptop based on where
you are to look that up and kind of do
their task but now with with Google
assistant you have a Google home setting
in your kitchen you have Android TV that
is assistant powered in your living room
you have Android auto while you are
driving and so on so users are using all
these computing touch points to actually
get things done no matter where they are
they want to be able to talk to their
brands they want to be able to get
things done while they are actually busy
cooking in the kitchen
so imagine your hands are occupied while
you're cooking you want to be able to
ask Google whom at that point of time is
that what do I do next with in the past
that I'm making and so on right
so assistant is becoming a lot more
mainstream these computing touch points
are everywhere and they're growing as we
speak and both of these are feeding into
how the user experience and expectations
are changing the needs are evolving we
see users becoming lot more curious lot
more demanding and a lot more impatient
with what they expect from the platform
obviously personalized lot more users
expect their experiences to be
personalized you might think this is
this is obviously this is obvious and
you've seen this before but from it
being a nice to have personalization is
becoming a table stakes so I'll give an
example just the Google queries that we
see which end with like for me like the
best restaurant for me or weekend plans
for me have grown up sixty percent in
the last year and that's a big number
based on the denominator we are talking
about users expect their experience to
be a lot more real time they want to be
able to get things done there and then
few anecdotes here when you think of
shopping more and what
people want same-day delivery more and
more people want actually to our
delivery windows when it comes to travel
the same day Travel category has grown
up by more than hundred percent in the
last year or so which means people are
looking a lot more for hotels to booked
tonight or flights they want to take
today or tomorrow and so on
so actions and tasks that people want to
accomplish are becoming a lot more real
time are becoming lot more I wanted in
the next 24 hours and so on and with
that comes everywhere they are users
want things to be done no matter where
they are and as I talked about as these
computing touch points are becoming
omnipresent they could be in your home
in your living room in your car in a
washing machine everywhere they want to
be able to interact with the right
partners at that point of time to get
things done they are seeking information
no matter where they are and we have
touch points with the Google with users
throughout their day so no matter where
so if you think of your full day's
schedule in the morning during the
morning routine people reach out to
Google home to check what their day
looks like what the calendar is the top
news talk updates music and so on during
the commute they use Google Maps to go
where they are going during the day it's
about Google email it's about the
calendar it's about Google search for
productivity and the evening as they are
winding down it's about playing
something on YouTube or even playing our
few apps and games on the Android
ecosystem right so we see users X user
experiences with Google surfaces
throughout the day and as and users
expect all those experiences to be
connected so if you think through the
whole day they move from Google homes
device to let's say a mobile phone to
their car to a laptop and back to their
living room TV and so on and the
expectation is that all these
experiences are connected they
seamlessly flow from one surface to
another and the duct this experience are
seamless and one of the big
that we have with assistant is to help
users get things done how do we actually
provide enough value to users where we
are doing things for them so we have
three customer journeys that we
prioritize and we focus on so when we
actively think of use cases that matter
for our users they fall in one of these
three buckets so streamline your morning
at home how do we make sure that when
you're trying to get out of your house
we can actually help you by getting
things done so you have less to worry
about and you can move out of the house
quickly so these could be very simple
things like turn off the thermostat when
I'm leaving do something a little bit
more fancy which is order my coffee so
that I can pick it up on the way to work
right so that's one big area of focus
for us and it will go into this in a
little bit more detail then do more
while you are on the go this you could
be on a commute you could be driving how
do we help you do more things while you
are in value in that mode and then
finally have a relaxing evening at home
so when you are unwinding when you're
back home you want to spend time with
family and so on how do we take off some
of the mundane chores of your hands and
and do it for you so that you get to
spend time doing things that you really
want to do so here's an example we we
launched Starbucks on a system few weeks
ago varies and this is a very good use
case that Starbucks implemented order my
usual from Starbucks okay getting
Starbucks it asks you for the drink that
you want the location and places order
for you so that you have a coffee ready
for you by the time you get to the shop
so Starbucks realize that like they have
a lot of users who come to their stores
and order the same coffee every day it's
pretty much like a morning habit for a
lot of us and on an assistant surface
they picked up a use case that matches
or aligns with that morning habit it is
less about you can come in and order
anything you want and although the fancy
scenarios that you would want to be
there but they focused on a specific use
case which is this is what a morning
routine for a lot of users look like as
I just want my order this is the usual
coffee I have every day
and knowing all the customizations they
offer this is what the user art is every
day in the morning so can we make it
seamless for the user can we add that
convenience and value to the user and
this is the examples that I'm talking
about the ecosystem is evolving very
fast we have thousands and thousands of
apps on assistant now which are actively
building the lot of brands on the
platform we believe this is the right
time for our developers to start
building their experiences on assistant
so why is this the right time assistant
is on 500 million plus devices on five
thousand plus different kinds of devices
that are out there so it includes the
voice only devices it includes the the
phones which have a screen and voice and
then through the rest of the year we are
launching things like smart screens and
so on so there is a big distribution of
the devices that we have it's it's a big
value add for developers to be an early
mover in their vertical they are seen as
an innovator and a good way for them to
set the precedent on what a great
experience in their vertical looks like
it's a great way for developers and for
brands to connect with new users who are
on that platform but also add a lot of
delight for their loyal customers or for
the repeat customers and then as I said
this is a two year old platform so this
is evolving we are making a lot of
progress on this so you get to be part
of fast a fast evolving platform and
shape what that looks like
based on the businesses you are in so I
think with this I'll hand over to Matt
he'll walk us through how do you
actually go and now build an experience
like that and assistant thanks Aaron so
the next 20 minutes or so I'm gonna go
over all the steps you need to do to
build your own action and everything I'm
gonna go over today you can start
building today so first what are we
gonna walk through here on the left you
can see a screen of an assistant action
directory page so this is what your
users will see when you share out your
action and we're gonna go over an action
called which language which tells people
about programming languages the other
two screen shots you can see our people
actually a users actually
acting with your action getting
information and scrolling through lists
and talking to the action so actions are
conversational so what's what's the
actual conversation that we want our
users to have so first the user will
talk to the Google assistant and say I
would like to talk to which language or
or you can replace the name of your app
once you've built it talk to the name of
your action and then the Google
assistant will hand off the conversation
to our action the action will have a
chance to introduce itself tell the user
what it can do and then the
conversation' will continue with the
user responding and your action
responding and so the user has the
information they need or the action
accomplished so how does this work on
the back end so once a user talk to the
Google assistant and indicates they want
to talk to an action the Google
assistant will route that request to
your action you'll have a chance to do
any API calls database lookups whatever
you need to do to accomplish whatever
the users asking you to do and then
respond with the information or the
response you'd like to send to the user
and then that will that will be
forwarded through the Google assistant
to the user so the first step in in
building an action like this is design
so in this kind of new space with
conversational actions you if you start
with your text a course start developing
first you can end up in a position where
most of the code you've written isn't
useful or you can kind of develop
yourself into a corner where a lot of
the code you have isn't useful so design
is incredibly important with
conversations so make sure to start with
design the first part of design is a
persona so this is kind of the
philosophy behind your brand and if you
already are working with a UX or other
team that's for your brand that has come
up with a persona this is a great time
to use that if you have if you don't
already have a persona for your brand or
your action the first thing you want to
start with is just adjectives so this is
just things that you want people to
think of when they think of your action
so things like geeky and overeager or
impatient you know they don't all have
to be very positive adjectives but but
you know something that embodies what
you're trying to get across
and from there you can kind of move this
into a character model so it's not
something that kind of embodies a lot of
the adjectives and then from there
combine all those together to come up
with a complete description of the
description of the personality that
you'd like to convey so after you've
decided on a persona the next step is
choosing a voice so you can send text to
the Google assistant and that will be
translated into speech and you have
several voices to choose from to make
sure it's consistent with your persona
but for that extra level of personality
you can record your own voices and audio
clips and send those to the to the
Google assistant which will be forwarded
on to the user or have a voice actor
record those for you so now we've got a
persona and we've we know what kind of
voice we want to have the next step is
actually writing the dialogue that and
having writing out the conversation that
you want to have with the user so you
want to focus on some of those use cases
that Ramon is talking about earlier
those quick and easy and use cases to
get something done and start with you
know very limited use cases and very
quick interactions and then expand from
there so and then once you have like a
few sets of dialogues and happy paths
for different things that your action
can do start creating a high level flow
of how your conversation is going to
branch and how each of those happy path
is going to play with each other the you
also this is a great time to like
revisit your persona and really make
sure that the dialogue you're creating
embodies that persona and the
personality of your action comes through
so now that we have some dialogue how do
we build it so first we need to set up
our development environment and the
place where you're going to start is the
actions on Google console so this is
where everything about your action lives
from the assistant directory page that
we saw earlier from setting up testing
and deployment you can see how your
action is doing with analytics and
setting up other advanced features that
I'm going to go over so the actions on
Google console uses the same projects
that
used to from Google cloud platform and
firebase so you can have all your
resources in one project and easily
accessible to your action so now that we
know where we want to start how do we
actually understand the user so the
Google assistant will transcribe the
voice of the user and send you the text
but how do we get from that text to
understanding what the user wants and
what the user is trying to get at so
this is where dialogue flow comes in
dialog flow is a natural language
understanding platform that allows you
to understand the intent behind what the
user is saying and also extracts
important elements of the users speech
out so things like times and dates when
you're trying to schedule appointments
or other custom parameters like product
names this all a dialogue flow also
helps you manage how the dialog flow
dialog actually flows and allows you to
enable the branching that we talked
about earlier and when you're creating
your dialogue so where does dialogue
both fit in the stack here so after the
user says indicates they want to talk to
your action that request will be
forwarded to dialogue flow and that will
trigger the welcome intent and then
we'll have a chance to respond to
introduce our action so how do we set
that up so we start in the actions
console here and indicate what languages
we want to start with and then start
building with dialogue flow so you start
building it you create a dialogue flow
agent and there's already a welcome
intent created for you you can see in
the screenshot here we're removing some
of the generic welcomes that just say hi
or hello and we're gonna add a custom
response specifically for our action
that introduces our action and kind of
tells people what the what they can do
so now you can see that you can just
write in a text response into dialogue
flow so this is just a static response
since this isn't really going to change
we're just going to create a couple
different variations and one of these
two variations will be surfaced to the
user so that they can and will ask them
a question of you know what programming
language do you want to know about so
that they know what our action is
capable of and can respond appropriately
so after we ask the question what
language you want to know about you can
think of all the various things people
might say there's probably thousands
that you could think of if you had
enough time and there's probably
thousands more that you wouldn't think
of that people will actually ask your
action so this is really where the power
of dialog flow comes in if we we can
enter all these examples that are on the
screen here as training phrases for
dialogue flow and dialogue flow will and
we can add a new intent called which
language intent and that dialogue flow
will use these examples as training for
a machine learning model so that any of
these examples will be captured in the
which training which language intent but
the machine learning model will also
capture any other phrases that the user
says that have the similar at this
similar intent of wanting to know about
a programming language so this is how we
actually add the training phrases so in
this which language intent that we
create will add some training phrases
here and then dialogue flow will train
using these phrases as samples so we can
capture these phrases and others you'll
also notice that one of these words is
highlighted that is dialogue flow
recognizing an entity so we need to know
which programming language is actually
talking about so we'll need to extract
out the name of that programming
language so that's what we'll do next
here so that you you can create your own
entities and dialogue flow using this
this UI here so we have five programming
language languages that we want to
support and we have them listed on the
on the left there but we also in the
right column have all the synonyms of
those programming languages so if
someone wanted to say JavaScript they
might be on their phone and they might
just type Jas so we know that probably
means they're talking about JavaScript
so dialogue flow will interpret that Jas
as JavaScript and for
that along to your back-end so we can do
that you can also use CSV uploads if you
have a large list or a product catalog
or a large number of entities you want
to support all right so now here's what
our stack looks like we first have the
user asking to talk to our action the
welcome intent is triggered we respond
properly and then the user asks about a
specific programming languages language
that triggers our which language intent
and then that will the information about
which language they picked is going to
get sent to our back-end and then we're
going to send them the information about
that programming language so how do we
actually send that information to our
back-end so dialogue flow has this
concept called fulfillment and you can
each set up a web book for fulfillment
where we the HTTP call will be made to
any URL you specify with information
about the request so which intent was
matched the original text the user
actually said any parameters like or
entities like the programming language
you defined earlier so that you can know
what the user wants to do and have all
the information you need to respond
properly to get up and running really
quickly we also have an inline editor
with firebase functions so you don't
have to set up a web server so now we're
getting into write actually writing some
some code for our fulfillments so the
first we just start with a very simple
map of the five programming languages we
support and the information that we want
to send to the user about each one of
those languages that we'll use in just a
second so this is kind of a basic
template of what you need to do in
fulfillment so there's an actions on
Google client library that helps us
parse out the requests coming from
dialogue flow and also compile a
response properly to be forwarded to the
user so first we're importing the
library and I'm setting up some
boilerplate and then that highlighted
section is actually where we define our
responses so first we say app dot intent
so this just defines which intent we
want to respond to if you have multiple
intents you'd like to respond to we only
have one and it's called which language
so we just enter in which language and
then we have two arguments one is the
conversation object so this is what we
used to add responses that will be sent
back to the user and then we have the
language parameter so this is the
parameter that dialogue flow captured
earlier that has the value of JavaScript
Kotlin or any other programming language
we support so the first thing we do is
we take that map I showed you earlier
and take the language and insert that
and grab the description for whatever
programming language the user mentioned
so we're adding that response about the
language first and then next we're
asking if they want to know about
another language in our second message
there and then that last line there is
just to connect this to firebase
functions which is what this example is
running on so now we now we've got
something working end to end how do we
try it out
so we go back to the actions console and
the actions console has a simulator so
this lets you debug and see exactly what
users are going to see when they try
your action so you can see here
everything from invocation of saying
talk to which language and your language
getting routed from from the Google
assistant to your action you can see how
that works as well as what happens when
you say it you can actually enter in
what your users might say and see what
will happen you can also see here we
have a difference between what shows up
visually and what has actually spoken to
the user and as well as a lot of debug
information and helpful things to help
you figure out if something went wrong
so so far we've only been dealing with
texts so when you're dealing if this is
just on a Google home or a speaker that
that is probably appropriate you're only
speaking to the user and the user that
the Google assistant can only actually
speak where it's back but what about a
lot of those assistive devices that have
a screen so all the phones and our
upcoming smart displays and and other
devices that have screens for that we
have a few different rich message types
so the first one here is it's called a
basic card so this allows you to have a
large image a title some descriptions as
well as a button that can go to links
that can link to websites and this is in
addition to the the regular text
responses that we defined earlier so the
actions on Google client library also
has some nice can
methods so we can just create a new card
enter in all the pre all the different
fields that I mentioned earlier and that
will be displayed to the user properly
whenever your font so another common
type is is a list so this you can use
lists for any kind of like product
selection or whatever when ever you need
want to surface to the user a small
group of items and they want to need to
select one so for this you have the
title and we can have pictures and then
there's some pagination here so that
users can select for multiple options
similarly the actions on Google client
library also has support for those list
items so you can create lists
programmatically and nice and easily
similar to a list is a carousel so this
uses the same kind of list selection as
the as the previous rich response but it
just surfaces images a little more a
little bit more prompt prominently so if
whatever you're trying to the trying to
get the user to select is a little bit
more visual this is a way to surface
that to your users so the last part here
is just as a way to detect what surface
your users are on so if they're on a
speaker you may want to speak to the
user differently than if they have a
phone and can see some of these rich
responses that we have so we have the
capability to detect what what surface
they're on if they're on a phone or if
if that that surface has a screen so we
can respond appropriately
the last bit that doesn't apply to our
which language example but is a can be
very useful is account linking so this
allows you to set a link your own
account system for your product to the
Google assistant so you can log you can
log your users in and provide contextual
information based on information you
have about the user in their account so
this is really useful if you want to
provide updates or any information from
your products in the Google assistance
alright now that we've got everything
working and we tested it out how do we
get this out to our users so the first
is the first is just testing on device
so once you've enabled test
in the simulator any Google any device
that's logged into the same Google
account that you're testing on has
access to your action so you can try it
out on your actual your phone or Google
home device that's logged into the same
Google account to see what your users
will actually see when they try out your
action after you've tested you yourself
you might want to test it with your with
your team so we have an alpha release
where you can share it with your team
and try it out with your team make
improvements and get ready to deploy to
your users after you have something that
you want to deploy to users publicly or
in a small beta group you submit your
action for review and after about a day
that will be approved - and you can
publish either to us a small public beta
group of testers or to production you
can also have different releases in each
one of these alpha beta production
channels so you can provide early
release features to your beta group to
see how it does so now that we've gone
through how to build an action I'm gonna
hand it back to Tarun to talk about how
to grow your business with it thanks man
so once you build a great action it's
very important for for you to actually
start getting users engaging with that
action so you the first predict user is
you have a good action that your build
so when you actually bring users in they
are delighted and there's a reengagement
on that so there are three verticals or
three different tenets that we think of
when it comes to how do you actually
start driving your business on assistant
the first one is discovery how do you
get your action discovered on assistant
the second piece is monetization which
is primary transactions physical
transaction in the digital go
transactions so you can start monetizing
your experience on assistant and the
third is reengagement for your loyal
customers customers who have come and
engaged with your experience before how
do you get them back into the experience
and we will talk about bunch of
different tools that we have available
so you can kind of accomplish that so
let's talk about discovery first like
imagine you have launched the app that
Matt was talking about and how do you
get more and more users see what that
app is and and and find that out that a
bunch of different ways users can do
that the
first one is assistant directory we have
a system directory on the web we have
assistant directory on iOS and Android
devices
this is think of face as the Play Store
for Android this is where users go in
and look for what's new what's trending
and so on today around 30% of the
traffic that a lot of our third parties
developer come get is from a system
directory so this gets a lot of volume
from users and this is how users have
been discovering a lot of new apps so
what does the system directly look like
I'll just go through that fairly quickly
one big experience for users is they can
browse the system directory they can go
through it
this experience is largely timely and
personalized to the users it's very
context specific
so this browsing experience might look
different based on the time of the day
are based on different users and so on
so if you think of the browsing piece we
show relevant suggestions to the users
in the morning you might see or your
coffee or play this playlist in the
evening it might be something different
and so on as you scroll down there are
many different experiences that show up
in browsing your app could be in what's
new it could be as part of what is
trending what is popular or what you
might like based on what what are other
experiences that users have engaged with
already the other way users interact
with the explore experience I talked
about is through search you can actually
come and search for different apps every
we have a taxonomy of around 400
different categories when you create
your action you tagged it to one of
these categories or more of these
categories so when users go and look for
let's say in the food entering category
they'll see all the apps that are part
of that category you could also search
for something and search triggers some
of these as well so specifically when
you think of a categorical browse within
food and drink their subcategories like
you can order food that's part of food
and drink and you can see examples of
Domino's there but if you are in the
recipes business that's the example of
food network which is part of the food
and drink category but is about recipes
at that point of time so I said X
load is a big surface area where you can
actually have your app and drive traffic
to your app the second one is an action
page every app needs to have an action
page this is where you would come in and
talk about what this action does this is
where you reflect your brand and think
of it as a pitch to the user on why
should they try this right so when you
think of the action page specifically it
has a second image of what you your
brand and so on it talks about why
should user try the app it has ratings
it has recent reviews it has stuff like
what your recent release logs were and
so on but but fairly importantly it has
this try experience right which is users
don't have to install anything here like
they just go and try and they can start
talking to your app experience so the
inertia for people who try out things is
relatively low and that's what we see
with lot of lot of experiences is that
if there is a good experience on the
action page a lot of people actually end
up trying that app so the conversion
rate if you will are fairly high once
users end up on an action page so how do
you optimize your action page I think no
points in guessing which is a great
experience on one of these but there are
four things that we usually talk about
like have a crisp image and a good image
the title is important for what you
create for your app I don't create long
titles which people can cannot talk to
or cannot talk about it's important to
have a right one there then a good
description is an important and
description is not like what your
company is about or what what you do
it's about why should I user try this
experience right so I think try to think
of it that's a pitch to the user the
last one which is actually very
important is the invocation phrases how
does a user invoke this this is how
you're building a muscle memory for your
users no matter what name you create
users can always say talk to French
Bulldog trivia right but what are the
other kind of invocations that users can
actually use it could be talk to ask
French talk French Bulldog trivia about
snoring or something like that right
create some fun ones create some
interesting ones that are relevant for
your business
but create multiple invocation phrases
you don't know what drives users to keep
coming back again when you look through
our logs you will see what the
invocation phrases are more popular for
users what are not and this drives out
of traffic to your app so we talked
about things that you can do on your
side by creating a great action package
by creating the great user experience on
the Explorer the second big piece is
what we call built-in intents we
announced built-in paints a few months
ago and we continue to build the
platform for it so what is built-in
intents there are a hundred different
ways people come in and ask for the same
thing
based on their dialect based on the
slangs based on their language and and
locale and so on there these these are
actually from real logs like and
basically what the user is trying to ask
for is I won't be stressed myself right
and then there are many different ways
that they come in and they ask for the
same thing
now they expect a developer like
yourself to think of every possible
phrase or what user might be saying in
your vertical is fairly difficult so
what we have is a concept we call built
in intents built in intents is nothing
but it's a standard taxonomy for actions
this is how when a user says all the
things we saw in the last slide we
actually translate that to a single
thing saying meditate and you can sign
up for that built in intent we have lots
of built in intents already in
production they are available in the
tool you can sign up for any of these
and we are launching more and more
throughout the rest of the year it's
fairly easy to sign up for a built in
intent when you go to the dialog flow
console there's a drop-down of all the
built-in intents that we have launched
and you pick and choose one or more that
are relevant to you
it's important to be right and relevant
about this the reason is you can imagine
if there's a lot of traffic that is
coming to your app and users are
bouncing off that's a bad signal to a
ranking engines so you want to be do you
want to be picking up the right built-in
intent set irrelevant for your business
this has been a big driver of traffic to
lot of our apps and I think it's
important to be selecting the right
built-in intents so here's an example of
what it would look like there's a
built-in intent for play quiz
a user end-user comes in and says I want
to play a trivia I want to play a quiz
or I want to play a geography quiz
whatever those invocation phrases are
they all get translated to a same thing
which is play a quiz and then your app
could be one of these apps that
participates in that auction based on
how it has done in the past and
personalized results for the user we
show a carousel of few apps that can
have been that auction and a user can
play and play with any of these so think
of this and these are very like I talked
about earlier like if you are in the
meditation space you are in the coffee
ordering space you are in health care
space a banking space like this is we
have built in intents for a lot of these
and you can sign up for any of those the
third pillar that we have for discovery
is what we call action links action
links are a link to your action or to
your app so they are pretty much like
your website URL or a deep link into
your Android app and so on so once you
create an action link you can actually
use it just like your URL in any kind of
any kind of surface so you can use it in
your websites you can use it in your
apps you can use it on social platforms
you can use it in your marketing
campaigns like in your emails and so on
you can even use it on billboards if you
want the idea really is this is how you
tell users that I have one more surface
which is more optimized for some
specific use cases but you can actually
engage with that surface so it's
important to think on those lines again
as I said it's fairly easy to create an
action link when you go to dialogue flow
there is a section in there which would
actually give you a link for each of
your actions you can create separate
ones for different intents that your
action supports so if you do multiple
things like I want to track my order
there could be a separate link versus I
want to place an order there a separate
link I want to reorder something there
could be a separate link and so on now I
talked about discovery quite a bit one
of the big things that a lot of
developers are interested in is how do i
monetize my experience how do I kind of
make once I start driving traffic to it
and start
putting money behind this assistant app
how do I start monetizing it so today we
support physical goods and transaction
sales on the platform
we are live in seven different markets
US UK Canada Australia Germany Japan and
France so and we are rolling out in many
more markets to the rest of the year our
plan is for this map to look a lot more
green by the end of the year and we are
launching multiple markets every month
and when we talk about transactions
these are transactions about physical
goods and services but these are also
things like you want to book a table
book or take our test drive and
reservations if you think or a makeover
appointment and so on so transaction
flows are fairly standard like if you
think of the building blocks and we
support all of these building blocks
today you can customize it based on your
needs and so on but the three steps for
most part the first one is you build the
order or build a cart kind of thing this
is where you figure out what's the plot
a user wants to buy you upsell
cross-sell other things
what's the reservation the user wants
what time works for them and things like
that so think on those lines but the
first step is you build an order once
you build an order you propose the order
to the user is that are you able to
confirm or this is the right payment
method you are using and so on so you
confirm the order the transaction goes
through the third piece is very
important when it comes to an assistant
surface it sent updates on the order we
have API is where you can push in
updates on the order so if it's a
reservation your reservation has been
confirmed or your table is now ready or
sorry we had to push out the reservation
by half an hour and things like that if
it's a transaction things like your
package has been shaped or it's arrived
and so on are important to send to the
user more proactively we support
multiple helpers to make it easy for our
developers to build transactions there's
a location helper if you want the
current location the user we have
address helpers if you want that really
delivery address of the user we have
payment helpers where we can actually
help with payment instruments Google has
on file for users
we have payment credentials for hundreds
of millions of users through our Google
Play a Google pay offering and you can
use those helpers matt talked about you
also have account linking helpers
to make it easy for you to link account
with Google users we are also piloting
digital goods digital goods are also
another way developers can monetize
their experiences so when I talk about
digital goods think of in-app digital
goods like if you're in the gaming
industry you can sell coins and gems and
extra lives turns play time and things
like that and that's a fairly big
business when it comes to digital goods
we also now support subscription
services which is if you're in the
premium content space like news or
premium subscriptions premium services
this is one way to monetize your
experience which is through
subscriptions or music for that matter
and then the third thing is digital
assets like a digital book or a movies
and stuff like that you can sell that on
the platform too and that's other
digital goods that we support
so across physical goods services
reservations digital goods we have a
good portfolio of ways our developers
can come in and create transactional
experiences on assistent when you
actually figure out the right use case
that works for users an assistant
surfaces this is something that helps
you monetize those experiences for your
users and then the last piece I'll talk
about is how do you drive reengagement
for users you have loyal customers or
you have customers you've tried your
experience once how do you bring them
back and what are the platform
constructs we support so you can bring
users back into your experience is the
same side I had earlier on is we have
touch points with users throughout the
day and we offer channels to developers
so that they can reach back to their
users at different points of this
journey so if you if you are a use case
where which you want more and more users
to engage in the morning like we have
different ways you can actually get
become part of that habit for users or
throughout the day or through the
evening routine and so on so let me talk
about an example of that we have
something that we call routines we have
lot of default routines that we have
created for users routines is nothing
but it is multiple actions bundled to a
single command so from a user's
perspective let's say user says good
morning or hey Google good morning it it
kicks off a series of actions for the
user so it can turn off their heat it
can move their phone out of the silent
mode it tells the user about the top
news their stock portfolio updates it
tells about their calendar how their
commute is going to be for to work and
so on and a user can configure it set it
up and so on but that's just one example
of a routine and you as a developer
could has a way to to get become part of
the routines like a tip of the day or
the thought of the day or how long is
the wait line at at Caltrain and things
like that so this is one way where you
can proactively be part of users
journeys or your action can be a
proactive part of user journeys and then
many more that we have out there we this
is a big engagement point for users
today where we see users using these
routines a lot because it helps them
make certain part of the day a lot more
seamless and efficient a fairly easy way
for you as a developer to sign up for
intense or for any of these routines if
you go to the console it's an opt-in you
sign up saying I want my action to be
eligible for any of these routines and
you turn on that radio button and your
your option shows up to users to be part
of that routine there are couple of
other ways that we support to drive
reengagement the first one is daily
updates the thing with daily updates is
that these are the updates that Google
sends to the user saying we think this
is a relevant experience for you or this
is the relevant call to action for you
we work with developers to figure out
what are the right ones to send to the
user and that's one way where we can be
proactive the second piece is push
notifications this is a like the push
notifications you have on the app
ecosystem
users opt into getting push
notifications from you like the example
from a square here and users will
proactively see every time you want to
push an update so this could be an
update in terms of there is a new
product available or you signed up for a
certain deal that's available or a deal
of the day or whatever it is so you can
think of what is relevant for your
business
but you can start pushing out
notifications to the user through
various google surfaces not just on the
assistant site so that's all that I had
in terms of how do you drive
reengagement for your users we have a
lot of assets and resources out there
that you can use to learn more about
this we have best practices on design
how to create the right design examples
that you want to sell tickets we have
examples on how you do that you want to
create games your examples on how to
create that and for different parts of
the different verticals we have a lot of
example code example designs that you
can use and then you can sign up for a
mailing list to stay updated with all
the new and upcoming launches I think
that's all we had and thank you for so
much for your time
you